[Music]
the disorder which is genetic and
affects the production of hemoglobin in
the patients
this disorder is an excellent disorder
that means it is more affecting the
males than the females as females have
two X chromosomes in them
this disorder brings anime condition to
the patient and there's no permanent
cure the only thing that helps this
patient is blood transfusion which they
have to take for their life
it's a long process expensive and a
lifelong commitment blood donation can
be very simple for us and can bring a
healthier life as well as happiness to
this patient so on this world's
thalassemic tape that's May 8th let's
spread the awareness regarding this
disorder and help them with blood
donation